welcome everybody to um
new episode of families
today's episode is sponsored by honey
and raycon
i am today of course with my mom the don
arc
queen of the butterflies don are donarky
do you accept that title sure that's
that was a great uh it's a great title i
don't know who thought of it but
way to go fans and um
[Music]
today i am a caterpillar as i have not
yet ascended to the level of butterfly
i got a lot of crap
uh for last week families um quite a lot
of crap
for not letting my mom talk about her
butterflies
and you know listen
i'm listening i'm here for the ted talk
i'm here for the uh
the full tedx baby
[Laughter]
give it to me six i want it all
i want every butter mom you prepared
your
yeah yeah okay i'm prepared
i got my notes
so what was your reaction to the to the
um
the great butterfly drama of uh 2021
all my warriors out there it was really
it was very very sweet it was very sweet
all the comments everyone was on my side
saying don't interrupt me but i i have
to share something with with with your
fans that
in our family
you have to duck
and and
keep your head low with all the sarcasm
that's flying overhead it's just that's
you know we're just like that and um
we're very tight family we we get
together almost every weekend and uh
it's all in fun
so
well mom i apologize to you
i feel like i was just where are you
you know listen
i messed up
i was insensitive i was demeaning of
your passions
and frankly um
well the con i gotta say the comments
were really mean to me i mean
maybe i deserved it i don't know but
like the comments actually were hurting
my feelings i'm not gonna lie
ah
but i mean maybe i deserved it i don't
know here let me read some comments
there was like a
hold on
there's a fan going by the way to
inflate my caterpillar
outfit
so here let me take my face off you are
one juicy caterpillar i wanted to hide
from the camera frankly
but
yeah
uh there's a fan going should we just
turn it off it keeps my my caterpillar
inflated can we see the whole outfit
first yeah you want me to you want to
see the whole thing
[Music]
i got these really nice nipples
and
orange feet
kawaii
i don't know
but i'm going to transcend into a
butterfly hopefully soon you can tell
give me the cue when i'm ready okay yeah
let's turn off the fan just because it's
kind of loud you guys get the idea out
here
thank you ian ah there you are
so let's see
[Music]
let donna give one butterfly fact
without interrupting or shut the [ __ ] up
um i'm surprised ethan never got slaps
from his parents the way he talks to
them sometimes
they don't seem to be phased by their
[ __ ] son's shitty attitude wow
they're just that sweet of people
that's yeah i mean i felt really bad i'm
not i can't lie i can't lie i felt
really bad
the way all three children and gary oh
now dad's getting thrown under the bus
oh my goodness
you we ridiculed mocked and acted as
though donna and her passions for
butterflies was inferior to them was
actually disgusting to watch was so
cringe to watch you all chime in with
your rude unimaginative snide remarks in
the failed attempt to scrape a laugh at
the expense of another how embarrassing
for you
wow donna brings more energy and effort
to this show
than what the hosts have done for quite
a while now show your moms and wife
that's for you dad some respect
don't ever come to our house for dinner
if if you can't deal with that because
that just normal family dynamic
for us talking over right mom's always
been sport
if ethan can shut his mouth his mom can
have finished her butterfly segment that
she so passionately wants to share
the attention wasn't on him for five
minutes is that a problem
well you know what in looking back
i think maybe we should have just done
my butterfly segment
this week which we're doing now anyway
and just done the the family feud
to be uh to give myself some
if i can just get say something i was
not expecting
the butterfly uh well you told me
you told me to
to report on my you said i could report
on my butterfly so i did a whole you
know essay
not for the family feud oh well i i
misunderstood yeah so when my mom came
out with this six page like uh macarthur
or like a 911 commission on butterflies
i was just a little i was like well we
have everybody here
right
everybody's come together to play this
game
right so part of me wanted to keep it
rolling
but at the other end
i think i'm ready to retire i am the
worst person alive and i'm going ah
i'm going to uh stop i'm done
i'm retiring
something else you got for me obviously
so what's that yeah being a horrible
person oh
come on what is this the pity party i
know you can't find the victim
stop stop
apology accepted
yeah you guys know how to make me feel
like [ __ ] well some of y'all we expected
some pro butterfly comments and thought
it would be mixed and i would say there
was no more than
90 percent of the replies in defense of
mom so yeah 95 percent of them were
about butterflies and then the next
episode we posted which has nothing to
do with butterflies 90 were about
butterflies
i was like oh my god dude oh lord
yeah so
i'm the worst person alive you're not
the worst person what they say about me
no no no
you're not they say i'm fat they say i'm
not funny they say i need attention
gabby's worse than you still
oh jesus ted
didn't need to take it there
all right so um my wings are full so
so anyway let's do the butterfly let's
do the butterfly commission let's do it
so today mom you have my undivided
attention
we are saving the monarchs
they must be saved
well at all
this is what i was trying to say
last week
is that you know along the rockies
on the east side if you're east of the
rockies
mountains
then you go south to mexico
and if you're west which is us
you go to central or southern california
and the butterflies that are flying
south to mexico
are in deep trouble because of what is
going on
at the biosphere reserve because of the
mexican cartel
what is the biosphere reserve it is
139
000 acres of land that these butterflies
fly to and they've flown to for
centuries just lots of milkweed natural
occurring milkweed no no no they're
they're um
there's ferns that are on the tip top of
the mountains
and then the oak is the the pine oak
trees are on the bottom but don't they
need to drink don't they need to eat
milkweed
well when you're a caterpillar you eat
milk butterflies the butterflies don't
eat milkweed they just get nectar from
flowers
and um the last generation is the ones
that that do the traveling to these to
these places
and so i was trying to bring attention i
was trying to give a backstory of you
know why they go there and yada yada and
how long they've been going there anyway
so how is the cartel endangering their
habitat okay well you know
calderon when he was president of mexico
i think it was between
2006 and 2012.
he waged a war on drugs and what
happened was at the time they were like
i don't know three four maybe more
large cartel families and they you know
pretty much were in control of all the
illegal stuff that was going on and
because of calderon
he busted up these large cartels and
what happened was you suddenly got like
shattered
and you have a bunch of these little
tiny cartels and basically
that's what's what's happened and they
are
causing all kinds of havoc
so so
the big cartels was better for the
butterflies no but but now you've got
you've got a bunch of little ones but so
how are they destroying the butterfly
habitat okay well this is what's
happening here um basically let me get
my notes
here well you know they are
um they're taking over the land in the
in
in the uh in some of the preserves which
is illegal and it's not good for the
butterflies obviously are they are they
tearing down the natural habitat to grow
they're deep
they're
the cartels planting avocados avocados
avocados are the largest
uh
agricultural export to the united states
wait the cartel are growing avocados
yep they're growing avocados they're
they the cartel are growing avocados
well amongst the avocado growers is what
happens what they extort the
avocado oh it's like a mafia thing where
they don't it is they're they're excited
whoa the avocado trade is dark money it
well not how do we make sure we're
getting good avocados well the thing is
in mexico most of the farmers are small
farmers it's not like driscoll farms
where it's a huge company shout out
driscoll yeah good berries yes
they're they've got strawberries so hard
yeah the strawberries the blueberries a
lot of them are grown in mexico because
our friend david are that
berries no okay no he had battles with
them yeah they try extorting money they
extort the producers the transporters
the packers so but the cartel is
clearing land illegally for people to
grow
they've been taking over well this is
what happened
during the time when calderon was was
president and he was trying
they had to diversify when uh when all
these small cartels started to uh evolve
and they diversified um and what they
did was they
they started extorting their their uh
the producers the trans the transporters
the packers and then the owners these
small little farmers and what because
the government didn't step up
and and help the producers or the the
farmers you know they needed help
basically protecting their crops
themselves
and their products and so the cartel
stop stepped in and said okay we'll
protect you from the you know the bad
guys
and uh in turn you will pay us some
money and what happened was they just
became predators on these people you
know you make a deal with the devil and
that's that's what happens it doesn't
sound like they had much of a choice
well you know they thought they didn't
anyways uh so basically that's what
happened and they they took lands away
from these farmers and they became uh
informal owners
and uh
you know
[Music]
it's it's really bad for uh the
butterflies i mean i think they're kind
of um
you know they're kind of like the canary
in the coal mine
because
they're diminishing in their numbers and
it's really it's very sad but we're okay
on the west side of the rockies we are
yeah there's only a thousand left or
something no no no i mean between
pesticides and climate change and and uh
you know that sort of thing yeah we're
in trouble also
by cartels didn't you read something
about some butterfly activists being
killed by the cartoon yes the carpet
yeah yeah
dude there needs to be a butterfly
documentary avocados
warlords and butterflies yep actually
there's a guy by the name i would watch
that
there's a guy by the name of eduardo
moncada he's a professor a professor at
barnard college and he's writing a book
about the extortion that's going on in
mexico wow so if you're interested in
really who's this butterfly activist
that was killed
you know what they didn't say but he was
up there in the mountains you know where
the fur are and they were probably
trying to harvest
and steal the land and he's an activist
so he got in their way and they they
flip and kill them
four people i think well there was
there's only two that i know of that
they're investigating
um
yeah mexican government's right on it
yeah i mean the government is the
government
is so corrupt there's a word there's a
euphemism that mexican people use and
it's it's a word it's they say mordida
and that means bite
so you know when you when you're bribed
or whatever they refer to it as a
mordida little little bite technically
right
so what are we gonna do about the cartel
i mean is this do we need to invade do
we need to uh
no you just need a president that's
going to stand yeah you need a mexican
president who cares about the
butterflies or just
you know seems like a big problem well
and then you got the avocados you got
the cartel it's complex it's very
complex because the majority of the
farmers in mexico are you know although
80 percent that we import comes from
mexico how do we make sure we we're
getting non-cartel avocados you know
it's such a blurred line right santa
paula yeah california puts out avocados
but sometimes it's not in season and
that's why we go to mexico and the lines
are so blurred because there's so many
small little farmers right you know it's
really it's really a tough thing to uh
to deal with so
you know
so in short their habitat is being mowed
over and lots of avocados are being
planted but their their preserve is
supposed to be protected by law but it's
not being honored obviously by criminals
that's true that is absolutely true they
don't they don't uh
they're supposed to protect it but
they're not just like they didn't
protect the farmers with the obvious do
butterflies have an important role in
the ecosystem like honey bees for
example a lot they say you know if the
honeybees go
it's going to be catastrophic because
beet honeybees pollinate so many well
the butterflies also pollen they do that
same foam yeah yeah they do and they're
just beautiful creatures
you know so
i just think it's a it's a wake-up call
for everyone who
needs to know that there's animals that
are becoming extinct there's insects
that are becoming extinct and it's a
whole domino effect because you know uh
one thing affects another affects
another i mean there's there's plenty of
of insects that eat butterflies oh we
don't like them well that's who does
that
oh my god
uh there's uh technic flies that are
horrible so should we wage a genocide on
these critters no
no why just want to do the best
i think we can kill wasps nobody cares
about water no you can't you can't do
that
anyway on a good note if you could push
a button and kill every wasp in the
world would you no of course not that's
like saying would you kill a shark
why would you kill a shark well
you know they don't need butterflies do
they
what if we could arm the butterfly
somehow can we arm the butterflies with
with the difference well you know they
eat the milkweed
which is kind of poisonous so a lot of
insects won't eat them
but they're you know every everything
has a natural enemy
so that's the deal with
the monarchs
they have uh they do that i was wrong
that was really interesting right i was
deadly wrong
i
was
i was fascinated the whole time
i bow to you don arc
and i applaud you coming in and sharing
that
in the face of such disrespect and
adverse adversity
you know on another note talking about
butterflies dan i sent you a picture of
a butterfly in my hand sometimes this
happens for those of you who are trying
to raise but is this the videos
you're to put those on screen or do you
need me to
hold on hold on let me open this is this
the one mom this is the one and if you
notice
hit the this but i've had three and that
were born and what happens is hold on
their wings are correct hold on you sent
a screenshot of a paused video is that
right
no uh you can hit play on this oh it's a
video it's a video yes i was like wow
that's interesting
oh that's that's that's tragic yeah it's
basically what what
happens when a butterfly
emerges from its it's chrysalis
it hangs upside down and their bulbous
bottom
is filled with
fluid and it pumps into the wings and
the wings have a network of veins and
the blood in the network will straighten
out the wings and when they're dry
that's why they're hanging upside down
initially
they can fly away once their wings are
dry it takes a few hours but sometimes
what happens is they have a parasite
it's a
protocol parasite
is there anything to do about this well
you know it's really tricky because it's
it's very contagious oh [ __ ] and and
what what you can do
you know when you get uh milkweed from
from the nurseries sometimes this stuff
is on there and the only way to get rid
of it is uh you take 10 bleach and 90
water and you could submerge
the uh the plant the whole plant the
whole plant
in it just for a few seconds and then
rinse it off really good
there's really not much to be done you
know actually what you can do is because
sometimes uh very what looks like a very
healthy
butterfly
they have this parasite and so when they
go and lay their eggs they've already
infected their soon to be babies
and and the way that i mean hardcore
butterfly people you take a piece of
scotch tape
and you place it on their abdomen if
you're holding their wings once they've
been born and when you pull off the tape
if you look underneath a microscope
along with some of their
their uh
um
i guess it looks like scales you can see
the parasite it almost looks like rust
they're little tiny spots and they're
sort of reddish well what happened to
this guy
well he has the parasite so when he was
born he was not able to straighten out
his wings and i actually have him
outside and i stuck on a piece of wood
uh
a uh
watermelon
cut and so his proboscis
which is like their little tongue
can unroll and that that way he can get
nourishment usually these guys die after
two days but my guy's still alive so
he's just chilling in the backyard with
some watermelon right i have him you're
giving him a peaceful uh
yeah
ending yeah pretty much i have him
hidden underneath the ferns and he's uh
still chilling he's chilling and he's
got food so
it's the third day he's still alive well
the water comes from the watermelon they
don't they don't drink water not really
they get it from then yeah from there
does he have a name
no i didn't he's just your little guy
he's just my little guy just how i felt
after reading the comments
so oh and another thing also we were
someone was wrote me about uh aphids
they're they're if you look underneath
the leaf of a lot of the plants you can
see clusters of aphids they're yellow
and they're really a pain in the ass but
the good side is
that if you see aphids on a plant
there's no pesticides because if there
were the aphids wouldn't be able to
survive either
good news bad news no the aphids you
want aphids no you don't but when you're
picking out a plant and you see aphids
on there that's good
well it's not really good but it's not
bad because you mean you can see that
there's no pesticides on it
and to get rid of the aphids you just
take a little bit of water and
you know
you can just use your fingers they just
slide right off just just
it's not a secret you just yank them off
yeah you can actually pick them off and
squish them
like death to um aphid
death toll aphid
yeah well you know
aphids are terrible they get on a lot of
fruit and a lot of other vegetation well
do you think that now that we've kind of
been through this can i ascend to a
butterfly i think so i think you can
ascend i think you've earned your wings
okay thank you very much because this
thing's getting pretty hot and
uncomfortable
all right
yay
i
enter
the donarky you are a official don arkey
may i be a butterfly babe
you are a butterfly look at the size of
these wings hubba hubba no do i no
parasites in these wings no
i'm going straight to mexico this is
pretty cool
i'm declaring war on the cartels
here and today be careful those guys are
serious
you know i had a girlfriend who was
chased by the cartel on horseback ride
when on horseback when i lived in mexico
why'd they chase her on a horseback she
you know when i lived in mexico i used
to go over to her stables and i used to
ride she was just up in the hills riding
this is when they're
she was spying or something well she was
just riding and you know they had
marijuana growing up there so yeah there
they chased her with a gun and she just
like all right
nice yeah well now that we've talked
about butterflies uh the attention is
going to turn to my dad
dad um
we've talked quite a bit about your
antics involving beach balls
uh stabbing beach balls namely at dodger
games
and so um can you
so we've just we've
we've devised a
a test for you a competition if you
could see behind my dad there's a pile
of beach balls
and show them the uh pocket knife if you
would please we've got my dad a pocket
oh my god and a pile of beach balls
we're gonna we're gonna see how many
beach balls he can deflate
in a short period of time we're going to
emulate the the ball game
are you going to put him on a clock
we're going to put him on a clock we're
going to we're going to play people
booing at him um it's gonna be like the
real thing dad how's that poc how's that
knife
it's authentic just a newer sharper
version of of the original is that the
one you used to to attack the previous
beach balls well not this exact one i've
uh you had the foresight to go
buy me a new one but i'm assuming it's
for me and if not i'm taking it anyway
sorry dan
cause this one even has a scissors but
that's not the right
thing to use for attacking beach balls
so this is the same model though yeah
the
equinox the official swiss army wow okay
so this is pretty
exciting so here's what here let's do
this ian if you could please
just toss him a tester ball and let's
kind of just pretend like here comes a
beach ball dan if you could cue the um
do you have like the booze cued up
yeah but uh at first i have just the
stadium sound effect here
is going please hold on i stand up how
were we no just you were sitting down
when we were i think he had to get up to
grab the ball did you yeah absolutely so
maybe step back a little bit so you're
on camera
so let's just pretend you're watching
the game get the sound effects going
it's gone
okay can i hear it i like the ambiance
brings back trauma brings back the drama
okay so my dad is watching the game
everyone's having fun here comes a beach
ball
so is that really
would you grab it or just kind of stab
on
on entry
show the ball show the ball switch to a
bigger blade because uh
did not cause enough damage well it'll
deflate i mean that's the end of the
game you had a small knife you didn't
have a big one you hear that they're
booing you they're billing the whole
family yeah bring it
you don't know anything about facebook
so
so when you get a ball
um you kind of just stab it while it's
in the air do you try to grab it
i don't think i actually ever
stabbed one oh stop it no you literally
just said this is the swift army knife i
used
right to try to kill beach balls but i
don't think i stopped it was an
adversary i stopped him when i saw him
pull out the knife
yeah it was just that was enough to
cause panic in the
adjoining areas okay so i guess you're
going to get to live out your fantasy
here today so what i want to do here
let's try again in
let's do one more test and then we
actually have to go to break and then we
should do the real uh the contest the
contest right after the break do we have
paramedics standing by or anything
because this is a recipe for disaster
just be careful obviously yeah don't
don't hurt imagine imagine stabbing
wildly in a stadium full of people
packed together well i wouldn't be
stabbing wildly there would be sure
oh you were stabbing wildly when the
ball was coming toward you
give him a big one ian like let's call
it realistic one so go ahead with the
sound please dan let's get the uh
ambiance going
okay the beach ball is coming so you're
at this point you're focused on the
beach ball because it's near you're
ready to attack here it comes go ahead
ian
oh so you didn't even penetrate
yeah so so so that's game
over stab yourself
i clearly remember you grabbing them and
handing them to the usher and deflating
them
that definitely happened it could be
hysterical amnesia on your oh my god
all right that one's dead so how does it
feel
good good okay
so when we come back from the break
we're gonna line up the beach balls and
see
how many my dad can take down for a cash
prize oh
18
beers i'm saving people from getting
knocked out of their hands okay there
you go all right we'll be right back mom
do you know what these are
yes i i your brother bought them for me
i've tried other products and they keep
on falling out of my ears but these
stages these are the really fun
bluetooth wireless headphones yeah
they're great they're it's great
it's like changed my life these fit they
feel great
the audio is fantastic
sometimes you just gotta pop these in
and drown the world out yeah like a
butterfly
sometimes you need to hear that upbeat
music pump up before you see people or
stay calm with a guided meditation
you know but raycon whatever you're
listening to is the best way to listen
they come with a bunch of gel tips for
your comfort not like some other brands
they don't stick out of your ears that's
true
that's so true like a lot of them have
like these little dingle dongles and
they get very heavy but these fit so
good yeah they they do they fit right
well
uh listen raycons also have a 32 hour
battery life so you can listen to
whatever you want when you want for a
really freaking long time dude
they also start at half the price of
other premium audio brands so you know
and they really just sound as good to me
i honestly can't hear the difference
uh raycons come with a 45 day happiness
guarantee
you really can't lose it's a win-win
give them a try see what you think and
if you don't absolutely love them within
the 45-day period you know send them
back
it's a great proposition
create your own soundtrack with raycon
right now
uh with the code of families listeners
can get a 15
off their raikon order at byraycon.com
families that's by raycon.com
families to save 15 percent on raycon's
good deal by raykhand.com
families
honey honey honey honey we love honey
yes we do thank you for supporting our
show honey here's what honey is uh
we all shop online well honey
saves us
the maximum amount of money possible
listen we've all been to the checkout
page and that coupon field just taunts
us because you know you know there's a
bomb ass coupon out there that's going
to save you a bunch of money but like
are you really put it willing to put in
the effort to try to find that coupon to
sift through emails or websites it's
like honey does that for you it
automatically scours the internet and
inputs the best coupon code that's going
to save you the most money automatically
at checkout it's a free shopping tool
boom it's a uh it's a a browsing uh
extension that you can install in just
two clicks
um
they support over 30 000 stores online
that range from tech gaming products
popular fashion brands and even food
delivery what the heck
you know imagine you're shopping at one
of your favorite websites for me
my website i mean i like i like um
electronics let's say uh
you know new egg love new egg i'm
shopping for computer parts let's say
i'm getting a new video card
put that in the checkout and those
things are expensive like 1500 bucks all
of a sudden it pops up you just saved
100
that's great apply coupon it's so simple
it's free money
and you know that happens all the time
ela shopping for clothing all the time
like levi's she buys i remember recently
she bought some shoes and jeans from
levi's saved like 100 bucks you know
you don't even expect it you don't think
about it
uh when you check out the honey button
drops down all you have to do is click
apply coupon wait a few seconds honey
searches for coupons it can find for
that site and if honey finds a working
coupon you'll watch the price drop bada
you know honey has found it's over 17
million members over two billion dollars
in savings wow that's a lot
so if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out on free
savings it's literally free and installs
in just a few seconds and by getting it
you're going to be doing yourself a
solid and supporting this podcast thank
you very much i wouldn't recommend honey
and left unless i used it personally and
me and elo love using honey go to uh get
honey for free at joinhoney.com
families
that's joinhoney.com
families
yay
we are back from break
and the big beach ball stabbing
competition is on my dad is warming up
his stabbing hand
there's a lot on the line here today 25
per beach ball we have 33 beach balls
for a total potential winnings of
825 dollars wow
how you feeling dad you feeling ready
how's your you you're you've got a new
shoulder there shoulders good the arm is
uh
almost
better than new
wow so we're getting there okay so how
are you feeling you're feeling lucky
you're thinking how much you thinking
you're gonna be getting today here
feeling very stabby
geez i don't know five at least i'd like
five at least so i can take mom out to a
nice dinner here we go again yeah okay
all right that's all right all right so
let's all get in place and let's get
ready to put the time on the clock
you're gonna have one minute okay can we
make it feel like a real ballpark take
me out to the ball
yes we have that planned as you know
okay
all right so we have one minute on clock
gary are you ready
one minute doesn't seem like much time
that's what you get i'm ready all right
here we go
ready
set
go
[Music]
[Applause]
is
seven six five four
three
two
one
that's it
that's time
okay my dad
a little sketchy there little
opportunistic
going for the balls on the ground
interesting but they had been thrown
absolutely talking to my throwables so
those had been thrown at me so those
were fair game yeah i think technically
you're probably right we didn't outline
the rules on that these are not
okay so we're gonna go do a final count
and see
how many balls my dad got and he did a
lot of damage at the end after the clock
expire or not after the clock is bad no
but there was like you did like 10 balls
on the floor there real fast
maybe three or four but again they were
thrown out you're right they're wearing
their balls absolutely no rules were
laid down no
ushers came to throw me out no they
thanked me actually well of course they
shall thank you okay you i love you
remember her name after all these
decades the same as my sister okay that
was the young lady that emailed me not
oh not the actual unless you're from
dodger stadium right okay let's do a
count we'll be right back
we're back
all right let's count the balls dad
all right let's do here we go
i want to know what you think you got
one 24 25
two
three three
four
four
five five that's better
six seven
eight
nine make sure he's only pulling out one
at a time there donna
eleven wow
twelve oh my goodness
thirteen this man's a beast
and then there's one more here on the
floor
which makes 21.
the
wow
knows how to ruin a ball game king of
stabbing thank you very much what is
that that's uh 25 dollars a piece right
yeah so it's 525 525
oh my god
thank you sweetheart that'll pay for it
thanks babe that was great tickets oh
lord did not have to remember a phrase
either that time hey i did okay with
those phrases
especially with on god and do you want
to save this uh as a first souvenir or
i'm gonna make a collage out of it
okay sure so we'll we'll set these aside
for you
so congratulations thank you thank you
yeah i don't want to spill your water
you just get these off the table okay
fantastic wow
thank you exciting time
look at the mess on the floor
is this going to be a weekly thing yeah
you
would all right you want to do advice
mom oh sure all right we got some pretty
good ones here today actually
uh let's start from the top here
uh uh please help me
hi ethan and donna i've been with my
boyfriend for four years now and living
with him for years as well
at our last place we had two bedrooms
one for his office video game room and
one for us to share
he spent 90 of his time in there always
keeping the door locked and i had to
knock before coming in now we're moved
into a new place and have the same setup
but his room doesn't have a lock he
recently asked me if i can still knock
and today i noticed that he put stuff in
front of the door so it would be harder
for me to open he barricaded the door
he said
it was a warning to himself
he said it was a warning to himself that
i'm there and he feels vulnerable when i
just come in
i'm really weirded out by it and not
sure what to think
i keep thinking about how if we have
kids someday i don't want them to have
their dad spend so much time in his
bedroom
behind a locked door what do you guys
think sincerely anonymous worried and
confused
i mean he's jerking off
you think that's
all
for she says he spends most of his time
behind that door how much jerking off
can he do
well
i don't know whatever he's doing i think
when you meet someone and have the
potential for a relationship you want
someone as close to
normal as possible and talk
talk about a red flag i mean what more
could this guy be doing to say there's
something wrong with me because that is
not normal behavior by any means
so they've been together for four years
you want to take a stab at them you've
been together for four years
they've been living together for years
and um
i think it's very strange that he locks
the door it seems to me like something
nefarious is going on i mean he could be
a
jesus he could be he could be rattle
radicalized by al-qaeda we're gonna have
to believe oh my god he's rat oh
god who knows what's going on he'd be
radicalized i mean did she ever ask him
can we blind some of that stuff dan
thank you
child the child the cp thing's a little
rough with the oh okay but we'll take
care of it okay also al-qaeda too maybe
i'll just say i'll just say
oh
we'll fix it
yeah we'll take care of it all right but
they're great those are great guesses i
mean
are we still yeah oh okay um
i just think that she should ask him
why it's necessary to lock the door if
he's just playing games right i mean
it's not like he's taping something and
it's a sound
uh stage well even then you would have
to lock the door i just think that it
seems
very
yeah sketchy very anti-social behavior
and um he's got something high i joke
yeah that's that's the bottom line right
i mean i joke about masturbating but
listen if you're in your room playing
video games all day you lock it when you
jerk off and then you unlock it
but how well do you know this you're
taking off to video games what kind of
video games is he watching not what he
said i don't think necessarily at the
same time although no hate for that
because some of those video game
characters are pretty buxom
okay you've seen
um but but probably not that
yeah that means big tittied right thank
you well my advice we need a button we
need one of those buttons too
what does the button do dump him oh yeah
we totally need a dumping button dump
them dump them i'm sorry very odd so
here's the thing
obviously you guys have been together a
long time so i don't know how much
you've talked to him about this issue
how much have you expressed your
discomfort with this issue have you you
know
how much do you know about what goes on
in that bedroom
apparently she's a no anything and why
do you want to be with a partner who's
so anti-social that he's spending 90 of
his time in his bedroom he doesn't want
to be with spend time with you i find
that odd
but the truth is he's definitely hiding
something
if he's in there and he's that guarded
with the lock there's something he
definitely doesn't want you to know
about and that's the that's the truth
yeah
yeah so i would try to
talk to him obviously you guys been in
relation for a long time i don't know if
i'm ready to
dump him
but have a conversation and then
and then dump them i cuz nothing good is
going to come out of that conversation
probably it just seems weird that he
actually barricaded the door that's just
going above and beyond yeah there's
something you have to be really afraid
to barricade the door you know that's
just so bizarre
you think he got radicalized huh
i mean who knows what he's doing in
there it's just really strange he's
doing something either illegal
or
something he's very ashamed of
but he's behind there all day long
my guess is he's probably playing a good
a fair amount of video games which is
really the only way to sit and blow that
much time in one place but there's also
something sketchy going on there yeah i
think maybe she's still in the
relationship because it's comfortable
for her
and she's been there and even as strange
as it is
it feels natural but
i she needs to get out of her comfort
zone and well she said she's going to
love him
well yeah no they've been together for a
while you know what kind of guy is he is
he like a neurotic kind of does he have
a job i mean what yeah really yeah we're
gonna have to say dump them on this one
sir yeah
let's just get rid of them
sorry don't care about any don't care
about anything
[Music]
find you a man that find you a man that
wants to spend time with you yeah mr
abby normal
mr who abby norman that was from that
was from frankenstein frankenstein young
frankenstein as a reference
uh boomer asked [ __ ] have i ever heard
it
young frankenstein abby normal
but i'm just saying pulling out abby
normal seems a little bit left field he
was supposed to get a brain for the
monster and normal brain a normal brain
and so he saw um a glass jar and there
were a bunch of brains in all the glass
jars and one of them said abby norm
abnormal and he said
abnormal abnormal that's a hell of a
joke
yeah you watch the movie the great
movie i've seen the movies one of the
great comedies of all time
guys i've seen mel brooks movies blazing
the saddles have you ever heard of the
abbey normal reference of course i love
uh young frankenstein great movie you
got yeah
i have seen young frankenstein
it said on the on the glass abnormal and
he okay how about it put the candle back
no don't get that one either so are we
dumping him though we were saying
goodbye no question we've moved on he's
dumped
dan do you have any insight as we're all
kind of aligned on this
um i i agree that it sounds very strange
especially the barricading detail very
nefarious i mean
maybe give him one chance to in the
confrontation to explain himself or
something but if he'd if he doesn't have
a satisfactory explanation for all that
i dump them gotta go it's definitely cp
or terrorism right
yep something
so anyway yeah get yours get yourself a
man that wants to actually spend time
with you anyway i mean how how much are
you going to feel loved and appreciated
and validated by a man that's just would
rather be locked in his room than even
spend time with you next that's true
unfortunately my funny
unfortunately
unfortunately here we go unfortunate but
funny story about my anus oh hello h3
crew recently my husband and i have been
experimenting with bigger toys like
donna mentioned
oh jesus christ
do you have kids
i suppose we went too far one night and
i felt a strange sensation and my anus
had prolapsed
i panicked
but but eventually it went back to its
natural position it's been a few weeks
now but i still get anxiety every time i
need to push to poop do you have any
advice to help with this anxiety
well let me just say if you continue
with the large toy
you know you can have trouble with your
bowel
your bowels hold being able you're not
talking
[Music]
i mean your large intestines can come
out
that's what she said she said her she
prolapsed she could i mean
if it gets really bad you need surgery
you know if she's into this kind of sex
just get a smaller toy but she likes the
big toy that's what she's into
did she say she liked the baby yeah
she's a size queen she said well she
said mimei has been experimenting with
bigger toys but we went too far one
night and i felt some straight sensation
in terms of my anus prolapsed i panicked
and went back to his natural position
but oh no so so she's scared when she
poops and she's wondering yeah cause you
you don't have control if it prolapses
you think the damage is done i wonder no
i'm sure the body will go back to normal
but she if she continues doing it on a
regular basis so she'll need surgery
down clearly definitely
like toothpick
she might want to reach out to someone
more experienced with things like this
like team skeet for example oh dad
team skeet are they offering uh oh boy
sexual wellness ability those people
seem to be better versus yeah did you
ever get any follow-up from team skeet
for when you wore their merch
i did okay well just uh you know
they wanted to and and what has did was
just a joke no they wanted to you know
do something else but i just wasn't
comfortable because you have a a fan
base of
really mixed and younger people like i'm
not
so they wanted to do a team skied
sponsorship for you yeah so well not
whoa
no for the podcast oh you didn't pass
that opportunity to me keemskeep wants
to sponsor the podcast let's get that
cheddar
dancing
did they mention any prices
no they wouldn't even let us do adam and
eve on youtube we're not doing team
skeet yeah right while we're talking
about it now all they have to do is pay
me what if we changed it to like team
skate
seemed skate and then they wouldn't know
wink wink night
we're talking about teams i'd love to
see their copy i'm just curious i'll all
forward it yeah
yeah we could get it we can get some of
that guac
no guac we can get some of that not no
guac from mexico skeet some of that cash
over here you know what i'm saying well
like they wanted me to retweet the tweet
they sent me about
you know promoting them and send it out
and i wasn't comfortable oh funny doing
that either i feel like it's funny that
we can do it because now you're actually
working with this with this
team
you know the least we could do is going
to collect
all right
we'll reach out
just so awesome
it's pretty funny that my dad is is uh
liaisoning with team ski
thanks to your mother brian uh my
son-in-law ended up with with uh most of
the merch yeah he doesn't wear that does
he of course you know
he's a school teacher yeah let's not
wear that what would be better to wear
that is awesome
let's let's not wear that to school no
that would be bad
yeah i'm right skeet some of that money
over here
all right
so go ahead and retweet that out no no
absolutely not i'm not retweeting
oh no
all right so anyway back to the anus uh
the the size queen we're saying size
down she's saying well help with anxiety
i don't know meditation you know
well she's she's anxious because she's
afraid and if you're afraid don't do it
address the fear size down if you're in
a state where cannabis is legal
that might be a little bit
cbd
can i can i reject with a little advice
sure uh
if you have anxiety because you had a
prolapsed anus you may want to consult
with a medical professional rather than
um some podcast hosts because that like
as hannah indicated that could actually
be yeah she might be fairly serious a
proctologist yeah yeah
that may reduce your anxiety as well if
a doctor were to tell you it's all good
rather than she can go to her
gynecologist and there you go do you
think a gynecologist is qualified to to
assess a prolapsed anus yeah
the degano would be like what though
oh my god
how did you do that what is wrong with
you
it was how big
[Laughter]
probably see it a lot to tell you the
truth yeah i mean listen
well based on if it just if you go over
to like the p-hub i mean it seems like
women are people not just women so
everyone's walking around with prolapse
anuses if you ask them over there
it's just common it's like it's like a
third pocket you could store change in
it and everything
it's just an accessory at this point
i wonder what the emergency room doctors
see they must see all kinds of craziness
yeah they all have stories oh yeah
yeah i've heard people started
accessorizing the prolapsed anuses it's
so common they put like little ribbons
on it and stuff stick
i actually can i tell you
i have a friend who's a nurse and she
shared with me that there is a very
large whatsapp group with hundreds of
nurses in it
oh really and i probably shouldn't be
sharing this but i will i will not share
any further details about who this is
actually but i'm interested and
nurses often times it's specifically
sharing images of x-rays of people that
have gotten things stuck up their butt
it is it is so incredibly common that
there is a nationwide group chat of
nurses that that share and that's what
we call unionizing people
[Laughter]
would we find a hamster there perhaps
everybody just accidentally sits on
something right on it yeah like actually
on this 50-inch dildo
are you flying away
i'm just stretching my wings he's liking
those wings
all right so next one i oh this one is
super wild dude really in love with my
ob gyn
can someone tell me what ob gyn means
obstetrics and gynecology what is the
step
like
oh okay what is nutrition
obstetrician right oh okay great what's
what about the gyn
gynecologist
female so they're like they're super
gynecologists right they're ob which is
the birth thing right and the gyn right
they take care of women's sex that's
pretty cool and right and to be both
birthing of children ob gyns we love
that yeah
okay
so she is in love with her ob gyn that's
pretty intense i recently moved states
for my husband's new position before i
did i was seeing the same gyno for
almost three years and delivered both of
my sons with him he's an amazing doctor
and an all-around fantastic person he
was always super nice to me and would
joke with me throughout my appointments
i ended up falling for him at this point
even months after i've moved i keep
thinking about him and i've convinced
myself there's a tiny chance he might
feel the same way i want to anonymously
send a letter
to him
and if he feels the same way he'll know
who i am
do i jump in and send the letter or just
try to move on with my life this reminds
me a lot of the you know the there was a
guy who fell in love with his therapist
that's exactly what i was thinking at
the same thing
the exact same thing people fall in love
with their doctors their therapists this
is a bad bad situation can't go there
i mean listen
you saying he's nice and jokey with you
is not
is not mean his his
to making a pass on you i mean you say
this man deliver two of your children
for christ's sake
and think of your husband for god's for
god's sake as well i mean if you have
first of all forget about the ogbyn
you okay dad you slammed your ring sorry
you scared yourself the rings
uh forget about the ob gyn you're you're
wandering eyes you're you're considering
other partners why would you do that to
your husband first of all if you're in
this state of mind where you're even
considering uh other men in a
relationship i think it's time for you
to assess your current relationship and
deal with that first you know you got
two kids you got a husband who just
moved for a new position there's a lot
going on with your love you got to take
care of the most important people in
your life right now before you decide
it's time to move on then you got the
issue of the ob gyn which is just
that this this
if let me put it this way
if he was interested in you
by definition he is a bad person and a
bad partner right
in your wildest fantasy
of this guy uh uh
sharing uh reciprocating his feelings
for you
by the very definition of that huge
conflict of interest and violation of
his oath as a doctor he is disqualifying
himself as being a good partner so there
is no chance for this to happen it's bad
in every way you know i've had two
experiences with two different
gynecologists that were
i left i no longer was a patient
well one of them was uh an older man and
you know the the
capes that they give you with it's like
it's made of paper and it's open in the
back yeah and he walked in and i was
sitting there and he told me he wanted
that back
what you know like a disposable gown
yeah he was saying i want that back ew
what a freak i know like he wanted to
see me he was kidding he was he was
kidding about it like seemed to take it
off yeah he was joking like oh i i
you know
so that kind of freaked me out i never
went back to him and then there was this
other time
when i don't trust
i'm sure there's i'm sorry go ahead i
was just going to say it's male male
gynos
i know that's kind of creepy
one time i went to a gynecologist i
won't say his name it's really funny
though and uh what's see man
no but it's close is it really it's
close oh i want to know it's so bad now
i can whisper it in your ear yeah tell
me it
no way yes swear to god
no freaking way i swear to god that was
his name wow
anyway so i i went into
my checkup because i was pregnant with
your sister
and i'm on the scale with one of the
nurses she's weighing me
and i look over and i see this
incredibly good looking
doctor he's wearing a
you know his white
uh coat
actually at the time i didn't know who
he was and i said to the nurse who is
that and he heard me and you see the
smile on his face and i was saying it
not because i was interested in him it
was just i was horrified that someone
young and handsome is going to be
looking between my legs like that i was
like oh no
anyways so you prefer only old
well you know when you're young and
you're
embarrassed it's yeah it was kind of
like oh my god and then so turns out the
doctor that that was my regular doctor i
told you his name
he was uh he was not on call his
associate was that particular doctor
and he ended up delivering
your sister
and then
months down the road when unfortunately
dad and i had
separated for a span
i was
in the office seeing that particular
doctor because the other doctor wasn't
available
and he said i know of this is the young
doctor that worked for dr tush you
weren't supposed to say his name but
it's okay he's probably he's probably
dead he's probably he probably is dr
steven he's still with us he's certainly
not practicing anymore no probably not
anyway
dr tush yeah i was like the hell so this
so this doctor you know he's checking
me he's giving me an exam and then he
says he says how are you doing and blah
blah blah and i said well unfortunately
my husband and i have split and he goes
you guys are talking about that while
he's examining you
no this was after oh okay okay i was
sitting up
and and and so he says to me he says you
know i've got a really good friend that
would love to go out with you
and i never went back to him
this is not that was so weird this is
not the plate ah
gynecologists should never ever ever
comment on
anything like that because it's way too
sensitive that you can't do you have to
be extremely aware of everything you're
saying about the woman's health her
relationships her body whatever like
there has to be no [ __ ]
no chance that anything they can say is
is being even conceived to be
inappropriate i never told you that i
didn't want you to get mad yeah they're
just going to comment on your vagina
well sure yeah if they keep it yeah
that's what they should do if they have
a comment about it yeah no i think you
did tell me that did i i was always
suspicious of that guy
who you talked about frequently back
then
you know
look of horror i like that
can you freeze that
look of horror there
so what are we talking about something
that happened like 40 years ago oh 40
years ago
how old do you think your mother is well
wait 45 years ago okay 45. the wrong way
here
not going with my lead there but okay 45
years yeah dr tush is long gone by now
yeah yeah he was a nice man r.i.p to the
tush to the church
dr fannie
she should have been a proctologist of
course yeah he messed up
didn't what was that a seinfeld right
where crazy
ass
that was a practologist that lost them i
think of course
yeah you know and i i don't want to i
don't want to uh
dismiss all male gynecology like our
gynecologist that delivered theodore and
is the doctor that works with ela we
love him he's amazing he's so
professionally so knowledgeable he's so
nice well that's how he's supposed to be
that's how it's supposed to be yeah yeah
i mean i never had just but i'll say
like
like i just i've heard even from ela
that there's a lot of we are maybe male
gynecologists maybe they're not i don't
know just there's just
it's too easy to creep out the ladies
like eliza had a bad experience you've
had a bad experience it's like a lot of
women have bad experiences with male
gynos and maybe they're not all creeps
but maybe they just don't understand
emotionally how vulnerable a woman is
and that
well i don't know maybe maybe somebody
might have said oh you know i'll go out
with your friend but not me no i just
thought that was weird i think that is
weird that is so weird if i was a woman
i would be more comfortable going to a
female gynecologist and i've suggested
that to mom but well i i go to being a
female gynecologist
[Music]
well sometimes you can listen sometimes
you know you gotta you gotta go with
what's available
but like i said i love i love the doctor
that that does our uh maternity stuff
with eli
yeah he's a guy and he's super super
professional nice
i'm always in there with healer though
so
well nowadays you have to have a nurse
in the room
when i
yeah no no it's true you have to have a
nurse are you serious yeah so then
absolutely so it's cheaper to have
or well they have to be in the room with
women a guy knows when a when any kind
of a doctor it comes into a room all
doctor visits i think or just
i think it's just men i'm not positive i
think it's when you have to remove your
clothing because i know when i went to
um that's pretty intense well
i know that
it's probably a liability thing because
they get so many complaints and like
they're getting sued and so they're like
well let's just have a nurse in there
someone to witness what actually
happened right i think it's just safer
well yeah i mean it's like a teacher
they tell the teachers you have to have
the door open if it's a male teacher
yeah it's safer for them
so anyway should she uh try to do i jump
in and send a letter or just move on
with my life well you know what it
sounds to me like her marriage is a
little
let's focus on that a little
boring maybe so
maybe she should focus if she's feeling
you know like she needs to spice up her
marriage to get a huge dildo
no i mean she should that'd be a good
reason to go to the ibgyn
get a huge dildo prolapse or anus and
then go see the ob gyn oh god perfect
she needs to spice up her marriage don't
write she's not happy you're in fantasy
land [ __ ] god don't send that letter
you'll regret that for the rest of your
life yeah that's so embarrassing don't
send that letter don't send the letter
holy [ __ ] no
no no
and and think deeply about do you think
are these legitimate questions people
are i mean listen you don't know
it's hard to say i mean they seem real
to me real people real questions
well if it's israel
don't don't send the letter and think
about your life i mean the situation
that you're even considering you're
putting yourself in is so twisted just
yeah
yeah
accidentally sent my sex tape to my dad
oh wow
dear donna and ethan my worst nightmare
happened i accidentally sent my sex tape
to my dad i accidentally selected the
wrong video when trying to send him an
innocent video of my dog now he won't
talk to me any advice and how to repair
my relationship with him
i think she should send him a a a tape
of uh crazy stupid love
do you remember that
well there's there's uh a young girl
their babysitter yeah stephen carrell's
in the movie yeah and he has a he has a
babysitter and she falls in love with
stephen carell's character and so she
takes these these pictures sexual
pictures of her
and
somehow the father
gets them instead of stephen correll
i'm listening so you know it the whole
thing's funny i mean accidents can
happen
i don't know though like a really
graphic sex tape i mean that's a lot and
i i by the way i don't know how
conservative your dad is i don't know
how old you are does he know that you're
sexually active is he against uh
pre-marital like there's a lot of
there's a lot of variables that can make
this worse right on a sliding scale
obviously listen i learned at a very
young age you cannot keep pictures and
videos like that just on your phone
oh yeah that's way risky liability too
much liability man yeah how many
situations your daily life forget to
accidentally texting your dad uh a sex
tape oh you could do it to your boss
opening your vid your thing or you're on
instagram and you're posting i mean
there's a million ways you can expose
yourself like that and i just you gotta
be more careful than that
uh how do you really repair your
relationship with him time
yeah time exactly time
there's really nothing to do but if he
loves if he loves her
he just needs to you know yeah he'll get
over it yeah i mean it might be
something just like i'm
you know just say i'm so sorry you had
to see that
again i don't know how much more plays
into it i don't know if he's like upset
that you're not married or that you're
too young to be having sex you know what
i mean but just i'm so sorry you had to
see that i'm just so embarrassed and uh
i just want to give you a space and time
to uh
to you know
process it right
right and then you could send him a
picture of a prolapse anus and say that
could be worse
see i could have done this
i'm assuming there wasn't a prolapse
anus in the video i don't know there's
no details uh
yeah
i was gonna say
could they send us the video and we'll
we'll give our opinion but i'm not gonna
say that yeah don't yeah that's
if you do not send the video we will not
review it
we will we will delete it no i'm serious
team skeet i'm not soliciting that dad
that's not good
a race that's just not funny right what
was that what was that from it's not
bunny
oh i know that's a stern it's not billy
chris billy crystal it's not fun it's
not funny
okay
um with peace and love yeah you know
yeah i mean what was on the sex tape
right like how much did he watch i mean
you shouldn't he should have just closed
it immediately and i think how old is
she she might have it's a very critical
like if she's 15. oh my god that's
trouble if she's you know then somebody
married
someone's about killed well that's what
was in crazy stupid love the fact that
she was so young and sending it to a man
that was old enough to be her father
but it was funny it was a funny bet no
it was it was a funny bit i mean that
sound i'm sure that was funny this
doesn't though
and he never actually saw the pictures
because they were intercepted by her
her mother's song all right one more
here coming at you my boyfriend wants us
to be swingers
hi don and ethan my boyfriend explained
to me that he would love to invite
people into the bedroom our sex life is
great but he opened up and explained how
it's his fantasy to have a threesome
with me or group sex and he's really
into the idea of being cuck-holded we're
in a committed loving relationship we
live together have a dog and plan to get
married one day he says i'm the only one
for him
but he wants to explore
sexually as a couple
i don't feel quite ready to do this and
i don't know if i ever will be am i not
being open-minded enough he's the man of
my dreams
but i didn't know that he would want
this type of stuff i don't think he will
leave me but it's my fear that if i
don't give him a chance to explore this
he won't want to marry me what do i do
don't do it do it you're not ready don't
do it
i think maybe
he's bisexual
and this is his way of being able to
fill a need maybe um well i don't
or
he's
i don't know voyeuristic obviously more
voyage i don't know that i would make
any assumptions about his sexuality
based on this but um i think maybe if he
wants to bring other people or have sex
with other people it's his way of not
of saying well look we don't have to
break up and i don't have to feel guilty
if i bring people in the bed then you
know maybe for her the sex life is great
but maybe for him something's missing
clearly something's missing for him but
if you're not comfortable you should
never do something you're not
comfortable with i'll just tell you
right now if it makes you uncomfortable
if you don't like the idea do not do it
do not do it do not be peer pressured to
do it
don't ever do things that you're going
to regret especially sexual things
because those are the kinds of things
that can leave scars and regrets on
people unlike many other things and
you're in a relationship with someone
that's supposed to understand and trust
you and care about you so if you tell
him i don't want to do this i'm not
ready into it i'm not into it it makes
me uncomfortable then you know he needs
to respect that otherwise mom's gonna be
smashing that button that's right
dump him dump him yeah no your
everything you said is and the truth is
from what i've heard about these kind of
polyg polygamous uh things is that like
it's it always goes south it always goes
south because listen
well i think a lot of married couples
well not i mean the married couples that
decide they want to bring someone else
in the bedroom
it's pretty much the last stop before
they end up splitting up i think so too
you know it's how can you not
feel
jealousy you you will i mean
maybe people get a thrill out of the
feeling of jealousy and still knowing
that you've been allowed to sit in the
room so it's not like they're cheating
on you i don't know if that's a thing
but um
i just think
you're just inviting trouble well
usually
again based on my limited understanding
of these types of relationships it's
usually one person that wants to do it
and they drag the other person along and
one person that's that that's not
satisfied in the relationship for
whatever reason sexually or emotionally
even and they hide it say it's a sexual
thing but maybe it's something else
and um
it's gonna it's gonna fissure
uh it's gonna prolapse the relationship
yeah it's gonna fissure and prolapse the
relationship
so like just say you're not comfortable
and if he is the man of your dreams that
you want to marry he will totally
respect that boundary
you know if it maybe it's something that
you'll come to understand and actually
want and that's a day where you can do
it with him when you have a place of
understanding or respect and uh bound
and you have clear boundaries but until
that day comes and it may never come
if this is we're talking about
me having a threesome is like
compared to a healthy marriage is like a
grain of sand i mean you have to keep
things in context like you're talking
about sex is like eating fast food it's
like if it's fun i mean well not always
but like something like a threesome it's
like fun and and and you enjoy the
experience but at the end of the day the
next day it's meaningless it's fleeting
so
you're talking about the health of a of
a marriage i mean that's way way bigger
and more important than just some stupid
night of fun on threesome which is
literally just fast food for
sexual uh gratification so it should not
matter to him
no i mean he's clearly something is
missing in in for him in the
relationship i mean he might really love
her
but yet she does not do it for him in in
bed maybe he thinks he's a butterfly or
maybe he thinks he's a butterfly
yeah so just say no man
yeah gotta be mutual
if she can't say i'm really not into
this now he needs to drop it
at that point yeah
and by the way asking another man to
come into the bedroom and and have sex
with you while he watches
uh that's like asking a lot of you you
know that's why i thought maybe he was
bisexual i think some psychiatrists say
that cuckolds have uh
you know uh uh
really underlying potential
gay issues there
which well but listen whatever i mean he
can be bisexual and still marry her it
doesn't matter if he's bisexual or not
um but i don't know what's his sexuality
but um you know
it's asking a lot of you to be like i
want you to have sex with another guy
and in his mind he's like oh what a
great opportunity why wouldn't you want
to do that but like well you know it's
like excuse me who is this guy
i'm in a committed relationship for a
reason i you know yeah i personally
couldn't do something like that but
you know
dump him
well i mean if she's that afraid that
he's going to leave her no that's not a
dumb situation how secure is that is
that relationship she needs to just be
honest and tell him and if he says no
i i have to have that well what's going
to happen is he'll keep bringing it up
and he'll keep pushing you
and then he'll he's going to make you
uncomfortable to the point of probably
coercing you to do it or you're going to
leave so just know that that's either
he's going to be like okay you know all
good he's a good guy he wants to marry
you and you or he's going to start
coercing you to the point where you have
to decide like 50 shades of grey
i haven't seen that oh you haven't
i think every woman
has seen that you like that movie it was
fun the first one the other ones were
horrible
in my opinion
well that's about all we've got today
how long we've been going dan
uh i think
close to 90 minutes it's our we had to
stop and start a lot my clock is kind of
messed up but anything any farting words
for the uh butterfly nation oh my mom's
on cameo
oh yeah that's right why don't you guys
check before we go oh let's see because
we launched it right now we started then
we tweeted it out it's cameo.com
donna underscore klein my dad was
fighting for his own cameo dad do you
want but i was like well you guys should
do it together it's a better proposition
i think so but that my dad wants his own
no i'm not i'm flexible and flexible
quite handy with a pocket knife also
but i i what does that mean
you're gonna be stabbing stabbing
motions a reference to her that might be
good if you're like hey gary can you
pretend to stab me through the
phone my my boyfriend wants to have a
threesome can you put his face on a
beach ball and stab it for me um
something like that this is twitter
everyone's like here let me see here
i'll check yeah my mom's in some trouble
here trying to figure this out but we'll
get through it and i wanted to give a
shout out to my friend howard
one of my ombre buddies from my our time
in mexico who is
has coveted and is in a hospital in
mexico
receiving oxygen
so uh hopefully he will be getting out
of there soon and uh back on the road to
recovery yeah get well howard howard
let's go come on pull through he's gonna
yeah
yeah that's totally he'll be he'll be
fine
um
mom by the way as a little side note
here you have one two three four five
six cameos oh wow we completed one
together okay mom is about to get
you're it's not even about the money
it's about spreading the butterfly love
yeah no 50 i think it's fun should i do
one right here you want to do one on the
show yeah let's do it on the show
my thing with my mom is when i do these
here let's see okay i keep the camera on
her too long and oh it makes me crazy
when you do that she said so so uh jake
says donna
you are our monarch butterfly queen
thank you for being you oh and you
raised a good son so this guy yeah so
jake
we could be talking about sean
he he's asking for oh that's true he
could be thank you no
he's talking about ethan sean doesn't
have the podcast
right so that's a good guess
he says can you give me a piece of life
advice that has helped you in your life
so this is for uh your boy
yeah boy
jake okay you ready so you click this
wait so this is the one about he wants
me to give him advice yeah he wants life
life advice wow here we go this one's
from jake how old is he doesn't say
anything
okay
so okay ready wait okay oh okay go ahead
all right and
okay go ahead
hi jake it's donna on h3 families
and uh you said you wanted some life
advice i'm not sure ethan's better
advice than i am i think but i think
that
you should just take one day at a time
enjoy your life and just
live it to the at a time just you know
live your life to the fullest and as far
as careers go oh
well
okay
as far as careers go
just do what you love and don't chase
the money because if you do what you
love you'll be great at it and the money
will just find you
so that's my advice
just enjoy life my mom used to tell me
she said if you want to be a garbage man
be the best garbage man you can and i
was like well i don't know how much
potential because she goes the money
will always follow you because if you
want to be a guardian be the best
garbage well i don't know that the money
will follow that well you know
you never know you never know you could
you could invent something to make
garbage uh pick up easier all right well
right so anyway you want to sign off
what do you mean just saying thanks oh
thank you jake thank you jake for for
asking for my advice
take care ciao
do i just push this no no no oh
wait wait
ethan you're doing that again okay so
that was all included and that's that's
that's a good value right there
the ending is my favorite when
okay great so there you go you just sent
the cameo uploading okay
so donna
underscore good start yeah
fun right yeah it was fun yeah it was a
lot of fun i hope i can do this myself
when i go back well if you i'll i'll
help you more okay you need help call me
that that's pretty sweet once once i
once i get going i'll i'll figure it out
but i think you guys should do it
together dad i'd like to do it it's a
better it's a better value prop
maybe i mean if someone requested if you
know i was a fan i would be perfectly
happy just having the lovely butterfly
so you're afraid you're afraid by being
in her video you're gonna lower the
value of it
it's possible no
no no no you're too kind
i think of us as chinese food sweet and
sour chinese food and then hungry in an
hour and hungry
no i mean you know we're the ying and
the yang it's it's one you're funny
until then guys thank you so much for
watching yay butterflies mom
the monarch
the donark
are you is that stuck
oh my god ethan you always make these
weird faces what did i do
how could such a handsome face make
himself look so goofy what did i do
ah ethan all right guys thanks for
watching and obviously there's no
recording so smash that like button uh
i like these antlers
you